l'implantation à chinon des premières
centrales atomiques françaises n'a rien
changé à la vie quotidienne des pêcheurs
sur la loire ni à celle des habitants
des environs
pourtant à chinon est apparue l'énergie
qui en 1975 va prendre la relève dans
toute l'europe d'ici dix ans il existera
des dizaines de centrales atomiques
elles fourniront en 1985 près de 25% de
l'énergie électrique qui sera alors
nécessaire
il ya un prix de revient plus bas que
celui des centrales classiques qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui beaucoup seront
comme celle que nous venons de voir en
france du moins d'autres pays choisiront
peut-être d'acheter aux américains des
centrales à uranium enrichi la bataille
des deux conceptions fait rage
actuellement car son objectif est de
construire pour des milliards des
centaines de centrales atomiques
on estime qu'à la fin du siècle l'atom
fournira 50 % de l'électricité dont le
monde a besoin
[Musique]
mais déjà cela n'apparaît pas suffisant
aux exprès des gens au travail comme
dans cette vallée des piles du centre
atomique de cadarache près de manosque à
mettre au point de nouveaux modèles de
centrales pourquoi parce que les
centrale de chinon apparaissent déjà aux
atomiste qui travaillent ici à cadarache
comme démodé
pourtant un chinon il semblait qu'on
avait fait un progrès extraordinaire
chaque kg d'uranium placés dans les
centrales et des f1 deux ou trois
produits autant d'énergie que dix mille
kilos de charbon mais en fait le
rendement de l'uranium est ridicule à
chinon seule la millième parti s'est
réellement à produire de la chaleur 10
des atomistes de cadarache à chinon on
travaille pour 1975 ici à cadarache
on travaille pour 1985 en cherchant à
améliorer le rendement l'uranium les
atomistes ont découvert un type de
réacteur surprenant c'est celui que l'on
construit actuellement à cadarache
il s'appellera rhapsody
dans ce réacteur révolutionnaire il se
passera ce qui se produirait si en
brûlant un kg de charbon dans votre
poêle vous obteniez en même temps que de
la chaleur
un autre kg de charbon à la place des
cendres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce réacteur ap les surgénérateurs
en français rider en anglais il se
produit en effet une chose
extraordinaire pour le profane le coeur
en plutonium du réacteur et endurer
d'uranium naturel lorsque la réaction en
chaîne des dents le plutonium
elle provoque la formation de plutonium
dans l'uranium
en d'autres termes on fabriquera en même
temps nos rhapsody de la chaleur et
autant de matières premières atomique
qu'on en aura placé au départ comme
combustible
[Musique]
on appelle souvent pile couveuse ce type
de réacteur dans le rendement sera
extraordinaire ce n'est plus dix mille
kilos de charbon mais 600 milles que
vaudront chaque kg de combustible
atomique qu'on y aura placé
[Musique]